[Music]
a Las Vegas mom clinging to hope that
her grown son is found safe Colin best
has been missing for nearly two weeks so
she also says there was a delay though
in her son's case Victoria Saha joins us
now in studio to explain more about it
Victoria
Colin best is 26 years old though he is
an adult his mom says she is his
Guardian because her son is both bipolar
and autistic and the longer he goes
without any medication his mental
capacity will diminish she says soon
after she reported her son missing Metro
actually found him then released him and
no one knew about it until much later
have you seen him in the area where is
Colin best a question his family has
been working day and night to get
answers to I can't give up he's he's my
son let us know if you see him Colin's
Mom and Aunt are handing out flyers at
every corner and talking to every person
possible yes and he's been missing 14
days Jennifer best says her 26 year old
son Colin called her in the middle of
the night on January 27th for a ride
after he didn't show up she knew
something wasn't right is he alive is he
safe I have no idea where he is Colin's
mom says she reported her son missing to
Metro on January 28th morning but court
records show Colin was actually arrested
that very same night by Metro and
brought here to Clark County Detention
Center and released just a few hours
later documents show Colin was arrested
for disorderly conduct and resisting a
public officer they arrested him mainly
because he wouldn't give us the name and
I'd already let him know if he's missing
he's not going to know his name after a
few hours by the time Colin was arrested
he was already without his meds for a
whole day and if you were still going to
arrest him you still have to call me as
a guardian let me know hey we have your
son but Jennifer says she was told by
detectives Colin was released around 1
30 a.m on the 29th she says she didn't
know about any of this until she have
seen it up about her missing son you've
literally just lost my son I was angry
Metro released an official missing
person flyer to the public on February
1st where do you think they went wrong
here Metro uh everywhere I mean once
they located him on the Flamingo in Las
Vegas Boulevard they should have
contacted me because I am Guardian I was
confident that they're going to come
across him or find him for now Colin's
Mom and Aunt will continue to scout
every possible lead until Colin is back
home safe we have had very little rest
we have had very little because if we
can miss him and we don't want to miss
him
now just a few moments ago Metro Police
sent us a statement about how they are
actively searching for Colin and have
partnered with other organizations to
find him but they didn't answer my
question about why they didn't contact
Colin's mom while Colin was in their
custody back to you